This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Around the world, parents, schools, and religious leaders talk about the importance of empathy. We tell our children that seeing things from another child's point of view is a sign of wisdom. Today we bring you two stories of empathy. What makes these stories unusual is that this is not the ordinary kind of empathy we display toward friends. This empathy is much harder. It's about putting yourself in the shoes of your enemies.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在世界各地，父母、学校和宗教领袖都在谈论同理心的重要性。我们告诉孩子，从另一个孩子的角度来看待事物是智慧的表现。今天，我们为您带来两个关于同理心的故事。这些故事的非同寻常之处在于，这并不是我们对朋友表现出的那种普通同理心。这种同理心要困难得多。它是关于设身处地为你的敌人着想。
I think that the two big elements that are lacking from the discourse on both sides is one massive lack of hope and two this unbelievable lack of empathy. There's a reason we don't see a lot of this kind of empathy in the world. It's hard, sure. But also, one of the most enduring psychological drives in human nature is to be part of a tribe. When someone in our tribe starts seeing things from the point of view of another tribe, we have a name for people like that, traders. What was most hurtful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me.
我认为，双方论述中缺失的两个主要元素，一是极其缺乏希望，二是这种令人难以置信的同理心缺失。世上之所以鲜有这种同理心，是有原因的。当然，这很难。但同时，人性中最持久的心理驱动力之一就是成为群体的一员。当我们的群体中有人开始从另一个群体的角度看待事物时，我们对这样的人有一个称呼：叛徒。对我而言，最伤人、最痛苦的是，没有人支持我。
Hard though it is, this kind of empathy accomplishes remarkable things. For one thing, when an enemy sees things from your point of view, she stops being your enemy. This kind of empathy can melt hearts, bring down walls, and that's what makes it dangerous. And I'm staring at this wall of the window of the bus at the Kalandia checkpoint, and six million ghosts chase me as we drive through, and I wonder if they will ever rest. So my name is Avaner Gvaryahu, I'm 31 actually today. Growing up Avaner Gvaryahu was a model Israeli patriot. I grew up in a religious family, what we call religious nationalist family, and I went
尽管很难，但这种同理心能取得非凡的成就。一方面，当敌人从你的角度看待问题时，她就不再是你的敌人了。这种同理心可以融化人心、推倒高墙，而这正是它的危险所在。我正盯着卡兰迪亚检查站公车窗户上的这堵墙，当我们驶过时，六百万个幽灵追逐着我，我想知道他们是否能安息。我叫阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡（Avaner Gvaryahu），实际上今天我 31 岁了。在成长过程中，阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡是一个模范以色列爱国者。我在一个宗教家庭长大，也就是我们所说的宗教民族主义家庭，我去了
to a religious high school, what we call in Hebrew family. And I went to a religious high school, what we call in Hebrew or Yashiva. I joined the army when I was 19 after doing a year of community service, and I served for three years as a paratrooper in a special ops unit. Being a soldier came naturally to have an air. In my society, in my community, in my family as well,
一所宗教高中，我们在希伯来语中称之为……。我去了希伯来语中称为或杰西瓦（Yashiva）的宗教高中。做了一年社区服务后，我在 19 岁时参军，并在一个特种作战部队担任了三年伞兵。对阿夫纳来说，当兵是顺理成章的事。在我的社会、我的社区、还有我的家庭中，
you know, this was something that was discussed often. I'm named after a soldier who was killed in 1973 in the Young Keeper War. My dad himself was a paratrooper. My older brother was a combat soldier. The people around me, my mentors, my teachers, my counselors, and my youth movement were all, of course, in the military. So I was really waiting for my chance to go and protect my country and serve. That was sort of something that I always knew I would do and I wanted to be the best I
你知道的，这是经常被讨论的话题。我的名字是为一个在 1973 年赎罪日战争中牺牲的士兵取的。我父亲本身就是一名伞兵。我哥哥是一名作战士兵。我周围的人，我的导师、我的老师、我的辅导员以及我的青年运动成员，当然都曾在军队服役。所以我真的很期待有机会去保卫我的国家并进行服役。这算是我一直知道自己会做的事，而且我想在这个领域做到最好。
could be at that. But early in his military service, Avnare started to see things that challenged his worldview. He was often asked to pull a maneuver known as a straw widow. This involved entering a Palestinian home to use the windows on the upper floors to cover other Israeli soldiers carrying out operations on the street. So I found myself numerous cases throughout my service invading people's homes in the middle of the night, most of the time, after we knew that the people inside these homes were innocent. Because you do not want to enter someone's house if you know that he's involved in some terrorist organization. So what we actually did is, you find a house on a map,
但在早期的军旅生涯中，阿夫纳开始看到一些挑战其世界观的事物。他经常被要求执行一项被称为“草寡妇”的战术。这包括进入巴勒斯坦人的家中，利用高层窗户来掩护其他在街上执行任务的以色列士兵。因此我发现在我整个服役期间有许多案例，大多是在半夜，在我们知道这些房子里面的人是无辜的之后，侵入别人的家。因为你不想进入别人的家，如果你知道他参与了某些恐怖组织的话。所以我们实际上做的是，你在地图上找一个房子，
you choose the house because it's situated in the right place because it's elevated enough because it has the right size windows and you enter this house in the middle of the night. Now this house from that moment on belongs to the soldiers, right? If the family wants to use the bathroom or the kitchen, in many cases they need permission from the soldiers, of course the family can't leave their house. And this dynamic between soldiers and Palestinians was something that I was part of for many, many nights. And I think that that's where I really learned for the first time, first of all, a little bit about the Palestinians, because I was never in a Palestinian home before I started my service. I had no real contacts with Palestinians before I started my service.
你选择这个房子是因为它位于正确的位置，因为它足够高，因为它有合适大小的窗户，然后在半夜进入这个房子。现在这个房子从那一刻起就属于士兵了，对吧？如果家人想要使用洗手间或厨房，在许多情况下他们需要得到士兵的许可，当然家人不能离开他们的房子。士兵和巴勒斯坦人之间的这种动态是我很多很多个夜晚都身处其中的一部分。我认为正是在那里，我真的第一次了解了巴勒斯坦人，因为在我开始服役之前我从未去过巴勒斯坦人的家。在我开始服役之前，我与巴勒斯坦人没有任何真正的接触。
But also I learned about the power dynamic that I was part of. Just the fact that I was born sort of in the right side of the green line. Just the fact that I was born to an Israeli Jewish family gave me the power to walk in with a helmet, with a gun, with my uniform, and I was in control of an entire family. One night in particular, stands out in his memory. We were supposed to take over our house, and we were walking through the open space around the house. We made maybe too much noise or maybe we stepped on a branch
但我也了解到了我所处的力量动态。仅仅因为我出生在绿线的正确这一边这一事实。仅仅因为我出生在一个以色列犹太人家庭这一事实，就赋予了我戴着头盔、拿着枪、穿着制服走进并控制整个家庭的力量。特别是有一个晚上，在他的记忆中格外清晰。我们本该接管一栋房子，我们正走在房子周围的开阔地上。我们可能制造了太大的噪音，或者可能踩到了一根树枝，
and we started hearing screaming from inside the Palestinian home. So me and the officer who were leading our soldiers went up to the window where we hear the screams because you know we could be detected and that's not something we want and we break the glass of this house and we peer in with our rifles we had flashlights on the barrels and we see on the floor of this house an older lady lady, helpless, and she was on the floor, I don't know what exactly happened, maybe she heard us and she was petrified and she just fell off her bed.
然后我们开始听到巴勒斯坦人家里面传出尖叫声。于是我和带兵的军官走到我们听到尖叫声的窗户前，因为你知道我们可能会被发现，而那不是我们想要的，于是我们砸碎了这栋房子的玻璃，用步枪向里面窥视，我们的枪管上装着手电筒，我们看到这栋房子的地板上有一个老妇人，无助地躺在地板上，我不知道具体发生了什么，也许她听到我们了，她吓呆了，就从床上摔了下来。
I remember looking to the other side of the room and I could see at the end of the corridor some people or voices and it was her family who were petrified to come and help her. And I remember standing there and telling myself, this is not what I thought I would be doing. This is definitely not promoting the security of my country or the security of my family. And I started thinking, what about the family of this old lady? I mean, what do they think about me now?
我记得看向房间的另一头，我可以看到走廊尽头有一些人或听到声音，那是她的家人，他们吓得不敢来帮她。我记得自己站在那里对自己说，这不是我以为我会做的事。这绝对不是在促进我国家的安全或我家人的安全。我开始思考，这位老妇人的家人呢？我的意思是，他们现在怎么看我？
Moments like this are what prompted Avnare to start working with an organization called Breaking the Silence, a group of military veterans who want to talk openly about what they've learned. From Avnare's perspective, there is nothing on patriotic about Israeli veterans telling their stories, talking about moments they struggle with, or Palestinian families they got to know. But others see it differently. Some see it as treason.
这样的时刻促使阿夫纳开始与一个名为“打破沉默”的组织合作，这是一群希望公开谈论他们所学所历的退伍军人。从阿夫纳的角度来看，以色列老兵讲述他们的故事、谈论他们挣扎的时刻或他们结识的巴勒斯坦家庭，并没有什么不爱国的。但其他人有不同的看法。有些人认为这是叛国。
In one recent video, a group targeting Avnare shows a Palestinian attacking in Israeli with a knife. The video then accuses four human rights activists, including Avnare, of protecting the terrorist. They called all four of us foreign agents, or what they called it, were stulim, which basically means implanted, meaning my opinions, my thoughts, and the actions of myself and my friends are not things we actually think on our own, but we're actually working for, for in government. To us, it sounded that if they're blaming us for being spies. As I was listening to Avnare, I couldn't stop thinking about a study I read many years ago. Psychologist Lee Ross ran an experiment at Stanford University.
在最近的一段视频中，一个针对阿夫纳的组织展示了一名巴勒斯坦人用刀袭击以色列人的画面。该视频随后指控包括阿夫纳在内的四名人权活动人士庇护恐怖分子。他们称我们四人为外国特工，或者用他们的话说是 stulim，这基本上意味着被安插的内应，意思是我的观点、我的想法以及我和我朋友的行为并不是我们自己真正思考的结果，而是我们在为某个政府工作。对我们来说，这听起来就像是在指责我们是间谍。当我听着阿夫纳讲述时，我不禁想起多年前读过的一项研究。心理学家李·罗斯（Lee Ross）在斯坦福大学做过一个实验。
He brought in students from a pro-Israeli group and a pro-Arab group, and had them watch television news clips about the Arab-Israeli conflict. He found the pro-Israeli students saw lots of anti-Israel references in the news clips, whereas the pro-Arab students saw lots of anti-Arab references while looking at the very same new slips. When Arabs in Israel think about their conflict, each group desperately wants observers to know that they have been wronged. To acknowledge the pain on the other side is to somehow limit this claim.
他找来了一个亲以色列团体和一个亲阿拉伯团体的学生，让他们观看关于阿以冲突的电视新闻剪辑。他发现，亲以色列的学生在新闻剪辑中看到了许多反以色列的言论，而亲阿拉伯的学生在观看完全相同的新闻剪辑时，却看到了许多反阿拉伯的言论。当以色列的阿拉伯人在思考他们的冲突时，每个群体都迫切希望观察者知道他们受到了冤枉。承认另一方的痛苦，在某种程度上就是对这种申诉的一种限制。
That's why two groups can look at the same reality and see completely different things. I told Avner, his story reminded me of the study. As you're telling me the story, I'm realizing that one of the psychological implications of your work is that really when you try and empathize with what the other side is going through, there is something about that action that drives your friends
这就是为什么两个群体可以看着同一现实却看到完全不同的事物。我告诉阿夫纳，他的故事让我想起了那项研究。当你在跟我讲这个故事时，我意识到你工作的一个心理学影响是，真的，当你试图对另一方的遭遇产生同理心时，那种行为本身会让你的朋友
and comrades really angry. The idea that one of you would empathize with the other side feels like betrayal. Yeah, I think that you're touching a point which is true and I think is extremely difficult. You know, silence is not an Israeli disease, it's not an Israeli epidemic. There is no society, there is no community that does not live with this disease of silence. A big part of what breaking the silence and saying is, you know, the fact that we are talking about our actions,
和战友感到非常愤怒。你们中的某个人会对另一方产生同理心的想法，感觉就像是一种背叛。是的，我认为你触及了一个真实存在且极其困难的点。你知道的，沉默不是一种以色列病，它不是以色列的流行病。没有任何社会、没有任何社区是不带着沉默这种疾病生活的。“打破沉默”所表达的很大一部分内容是，你知道的，我们谈论我们的行动这一事实，
of course it doesn't mean there's no responsibility on the Palestinian side, but you know, when I do think about what can create change, and who has the power for change, I can't ignore the fact that in this specific point, we are the ones with the power. We are the ones with the power. When we come back, a Palestinian professor tries to get his students to empathize with Israelis. If you learn about the suffering of the other, what that help and your attitude for reconciliation.
当然这并不意味着巴勒斯坦方面没有责任，但你知道的，当我思考什么能创造改变、谁拥有变革的力量时，我无法忽视这样一个事实：在特定这一点上，我们才是拥有权力的人。我们才是拥有权力的人。广告回来后，一位巴勒斯坦教授试图让他的学生对以色列人产生同理心。如果你了解对方的痛苦，这是否会有助于你对和解的态度。
Stay with us. The psychologist Michael Wall and Nyla Branscom wants us Jewish volunteers to think about the suffering of Palestinians. The psychologists reminded some of the volunteers about the Holocaust. Compared to others, Jews reminded of their own group suffering, showed less compassion toward Palestinian suffering. The same thing happens with other groups. Americans reminded of traumas, even distant traumas like the Pearl Harbor attack, show less empathy for victims of torture carried out by American
请继续收听。心理学家迈克尔·沃尔（Michael Wall）和内拉·布兰斯科姆（Nyla Branscom）希望我们这些犹太志愿者去思考巴勒斯坦人的痛苦。心理学家提醒一些志愿者注意大屠杀。与其他人相比，被唤起本群体苦难记忆的犹太人，对巴勒斯坦人的苦难表现出更少的同情。其他群体身上也会发生同样的事情。被唤起创伤记忆的美国人，甚至是像珍珠港事件这样遥远的创伤，对遭受美国军人虐待的受害者的同理心也会减少。
service members. Trauma makes us turn inward. It creates justifications for the harm we cause are the groups. It makes it harder to feel empathy for our enemies. In 1948, hundreds of thousands of Palestinians lost their homes during the creation of the state of Israel. Palestinians have a word to describe this trauma. They call it the Nakba, the catastrophe. Just as traumatized Israelis don't want to think about the Nakba, traumatized Palestinians,
创伤使我们转向内心。它为我们对其他群体造成的伤害提供了正当理由。它让我们更难对我们的敌人产生同理心。1948 年，在以色列国创建期间，成千上万的巴勒斯坦人失去了家园。巴勒斯坦人有一个词来描述这种创伤。他们称之为“纳克巴”（Nakba），意为大灾难。正如受创伤的以色列人不想去想“纳克巴”一样，受创伤的巴勒斯坦人
don't want to think about the Holocaust. Muhammad Dijani used to be one of those Palestinians who struggled to empathize with Israelis. He considered himself a nationalist. In fact, as a result of his political work for Palestinian statehood, Mohammed says he was forced into exile from his native Jerusalem. He was allowed to return in 1993 because his father was very sick. And then, just like Aufnir, something happened to Mohammed that shook his beliefs about his enemy.
也不想去想大屠杀。穆罕默德·达贾尼（Muhammad Dijani）曾经是那些难以对以色列人产生同理心的巴勒斯坦人之一。他认为自己是一个民族主义者。事实上，由于他为巴勒斯坦建国所做的政治工作，穆罕默德说他被迫流亡离开了他土生土长的耶路撒冷。1993年，由于父亲重病，他被允许返回。然后，就像阿夫纳一样，穆罕默德身上发生了一件事，动摇了他对敌人的信念。
In the beginning, it was very difficult for me to adjust, but my father, what cancer, started taking me to a Iincarium hospital where he used to have chemotherapy. And it made me observe my enemy, the Israelis, the doctors, the nurses, the staff. I noticed that their attitude to my father was not an attitude of an enemy to his enemy, but rather a doctor to his patient. Another time, Muhammad's mother suffered a heart attack.
一开始，对我来说很难适应，但我的父亲患了癌症，开始带我去一家癌症医院，他以前在那里接受化疗。这让我得以观察我的敌人——以色列人、医生、护士和医务人员。我注意到他们对我父亲的态度不是敌人对敌人的态度，而是医生对病人的态度。还有一次，穆罕默德的母亲突发心脏病。
He was in a car with her, his brother was driving. We were coming to the Mongolian airport exit and my brother decided to take that exit. Muhammad told his brother he was being foolish. Israeli soldiers would stop them, harass them. Muhammad's brother said they had no choice. He pulled up at a security gate. When we came to the gates of the airport, the enemy brother told them that we have a secwoman with us and they saw her. They vacated one of the gates there and immediately called for ambulance there. When the doctors came, they found out that they cannot move her,
他和母亲坐在一辆车里，他哥哥在开车。我们正开向蒙哥马利机场出口，我哥哥决定走那个出口。穆罕默德告诉他哥哥，他这么做太愚蠢了。以色列士兵会拦下他们并骚扰他们。穆罕默德的哥哥说他们别无选择。他把车开到了一个安全大门前。当我们来到机场大门时，敌人哥哥告诉他们我们车里有一个生病的女人，他们看到了她。他们腾出了那里的一扇门，并立刻在那里叫了救护车。当医生赶到时，他们发现无法移动她，
so they tried to resuscitate her there, so it became like an operation room." These experiences changed Muhammad. He says he stopped thinking of the conflict in terms of Palestinians versus Israelis, and started thinking in terms of the Palestinians and Israelis who were four peace, and the Palestinians and Israelis who were against peace. And for the very first time he says, he tried to see the Palestinian in Israeli conflict from the Israeli point of view. He began teaching political science at Al-Quds University in Jerusalem, and he brought his new understanding with him.
所以他们试图在那里对她进行心肺复苏，所以这里变得像一个手术室一样。”这些经历改变了穆罕默德。他说他不再用“巴勒斯坦人对阵以色列人”的视角来思考这场冲突，而是开始从“赞成和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人”以及“反对和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人”的角度来思考。他说，这是他破天荒第一次尝试从以色列人的角度来看待巴勒斯坦与以色列的冲突。他开始在耶路撒冷的圣城大学（Al-Quds University）教授政治学，并将他的新理解带到了教学中。
But his students couldn't relate. They hadn't had encounters with kind Israeli soldiers and carrying Jewish doctors. In order to come to the university, they used to go through many checkpoints, so they would leave something like three in the morning to get to the university at nine. Muhammad tried to get his students to see beyond the soldiers they met at checkpoints every day. The university set up an Israeli studies program and an American studies program, and he
但他的学生无法产生共鸣。他们没有经历过善良的以色列士兵和慈爱的犹太医生。为了来到大学，他们过去常常穿过许多检查站，所以他们通常在凌晨三点左右出发，以便在九点到达大学。穆罕默德试图让他的学生超越他们每天在检查站遇到的士兵去看待问题。大学设立了以色列研究项目和美国研究项目，他
started to broach a topic most Palestinians had never encountered at school, the Holocaust. But Muhammad students, consumed as they were with their own trauma, could not or would not listen. One of his students was a young woman named Hanan. And she was in Israeli presence for nine years. So to her, she looked at what happened with Jews in Auschwitz, in Krakow, in different Bekanau, in different concentration camps, as if transmitting that to her own experience
开始涉足一个大多数巴勒斯坦人在学校里从未接触过的话题——大屠杀。但穆罕默德的学生们沉浸在他们自己的创伤中，不能也不愿倾听。他的一个学生是一个叫哈南（Hanan）的年轻女性。她曾在以色列监狱服刑九年。所以对她来说，她看着犹太人在奥斯威辛、克拉科夫、比克瑙以及不同集中营里发生的事情，就像是把这些投射到她自己作为囚犯在以色列监狱中以及作为女性遭受歧视的经历上。
being a prisoner in Israeli jails and being discriminated against as a woman. Muhammad told Hanan she had constructed a prison inside her own mind, a prison that kept her from seeing the world from the point of view of her enemy. When nothing worked with the students, Muhammad decided he would take Hanan and a couple dozen other students on a field trip to Europe. They would visit Nazi concentration camps and learn, first hand, about the trauma at the heart of the Israeli Jewish experience. It was a scientific project to study about empathy, about if you learn about the suffering
穆罕默德告诉哈南，她在自己的心灵内部建造了一座监狱，一座让她无法从敌人角度看世界的监狱。当对学生们的所有努力都无济于事时，穆罕默德决定带着哈南和其他几十名学生去欧洲进行一次实地考察。他们将参观纳粹集中营，亲身体验以色列犹太人经历核心的创伤。这是一个研究同理心的科学项目，旨在探讨如果你了解对方的痛苦，这是否有助于促进你的和解态度。我们决定带着这 30 名巴勒斯坦学生前往波兰的奥斯威辛和克拉科夫。几乎立刻，麻烦就来了。
of the other, would that help more in your attitude for reconciliation. We decided to take these 30 Palestinian students to Auschwitz and Krakow in Poland. Almost immediately, there was trouble. So I received an email from the president of the university. He said that I heard rumors that you are taking students to Auschwitz, and I would like you to make it very clear to them that the university has nothing to do with this trip. Another student came to me and said, you should cancel this trip, and that if you would go once you come back, you might be facing a very big threat.
我收到了大学校长的电子邮件。他说我听到谣言说你要带学生去奥斯威辛，我希望你向他们明确表示，学校与这次旅行毫无关系。另一个学生来找我说，你应该取消这次旅行，如果你去了，等你回来，你可能会面临巨大的威胁。
Muhammad did not waver. He was an educator. And like Avner, he believed he was being a patriot. Empathy he had come to believe was the only way to understanding and to peace. When they got to Auschwitz, Muhammad and Hanan stopped at the entrance to the camp. And then when she saw the, at the entrance, the, there was like a blackout saying, Arbite-Macht-Frey, the, so works at Setsu-Frey. So she was very surprised with that slogan on the at the gate of the aggregate of the Auschwitz camp and asked me about it and I said, why don't you lock it up?
穆罕默德没有动摇。他是一位教育家。和阿夫纳一样，他坚信自己是一名爱国者。他渐渐坚信，同理心是通往理解和和平的唯一途径。当他们到达奥斯威辛时，穆罕默德和哈南在集中营入口处停了下来。然后当她看到入口处，有一个像黑板一样的牌子，上面写着 Arbite-Macht-Frey，也就是劳动带来自由。所以她对奥斯威辛集中营大门上的这个标语感到非常惊讶，并问我关于它的事，我说，你为什么不去读读看呢？
Hanan learned the meaning of the cynical phrase. The Jewish prisoners who entered this camp were not set free by work. They were worked to death or killed. There was this big room which had toilets and we were told that every morning more than 2,000 people gathered in front of the room and then they make them go through there to use it and they are given ten seconds to use it and then they have to leave. And so it was such a humiliation for the individual. They were things they never heard of in terms of how human beings were humiliated and broken. As they walked through the camp, Muhammad noticed that Hanan and the other students were
哈南懂得了这个讽刺短语的含义。进入这个集中营的犹太囚犯并没有通过劳动获得自由。他们被劳累致死或被杀害。这里有一个大房间，里面有厕所，我们被告知每天早上有 2000 多人聚集在房间前，然后他们排队进去使用，只给他们十秒钟的时间使用，之后他们就必须离开。这对个人来说是极大的羞辱。这些事情是他们从未听说过的，关于人类是如何被羞辱和摧毁的。当他们穿过集中营时，穆罕默德注意到哈南和其他学生
no longer seeing the Holocaust through the lens of their own suffering. They were actually empathizing with Jews, their enemies. It was very emotional to them, one of the, and some of the, some of the girls even cried. One of the students was telling me, I thought that Hitler gathered Jews in these concentration camps to send them to Palestine, to have them ship to Palestine. So to them, they had a total misconception about what is the Holocaust, what is the concentration camp, what did it mean, how life was there. And so it was an open out for them. But back at home, Muhammad's colleagues at the university did not see the trip as an invaluable educational experience.
不再透过自身苦难的有色眼镜来看待大屠杀。他们实际上在对犹太人——他们的敌人——产生同理心。这让他们情绪非常激动，其中一些女孩甚至哭了。其中一个学生告诉我，我以为希特勒把犹太人聚集在这些集中营里是为了把他们送到巴勒斯坦，把他们运送到巴勒斯坦。所以对他们来说，他们对什么是大屠杀、什么是集中营、它意味着什么、那里的生活是怎样的，有着完全错误的看法。因此，这对他们来说是一次大开眼界的经历。但回到家后，穆罕默德在大学的同事们并不认为这次旅行是一次无价的教育经历。
The last day in Auschwitz, my secretary wrote to me an email saying that students have come in the Renshaktor office and they were making demonstrations against your own campus and they came and left you a letter of threatening your life that you should not come back to the university and that if you come back they are going to kill you. And the letter is with me and she said that there were extremely, there is a lot of enmity and an uproar on campus regarding the trip. So anyway, that prepared me that the reception will not be easy going back to the university. And once I went there, I noticed that there was a lot of enmity people were looking at me as if I have a
在奥斯威辛的最后一天，我的秘书给我写了一封电子邮件，说学生们去了校长办公室，他们正在校园里针对你进行示威游行，他们来并留下一封威胁你生命的信，说你不应该回到大学，如果你回来他们就会杀了你。信在我这里，她说校园里关于这次旅行有极度的敌意和轩然大波。无论如何，这让我做好准备，回到大学后受到的接待不会一帆风顺。一旦我去了那里，我注意到有很多敌意，人们看着我，就好像我是一个叛徒，背叛了他们一样。
a betrayer, betrayed them. At the same time, nine student organizations issued a statement on campus saying that this is normalization and normalization equals treason. Muhammad was forced to resign from his job. One night someone set fire to his car. He knew his life was in danger. He packed his bags and left Jerusalem again. This time exiled by his fellow Palestinians.
与此同时，九个学生组织在校园里发表声明，称这是正常化，而正常化等于叛国。穆罕默德被迫辞职。一天晚上，有人放火烧了他的汽车。他知道自己的生命处于危险之中。他收拾行装，再次离开耶路撒冷。这一次，他被同胞巴勒斯坦人流放了。
I asked him how it felt to be called a traitor. What was most helpful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. That was really what was most painful for me. Also the fact that I have dedicated all my life for the Palestinian cause and suddenly I'm a traitor for that cause, so that also was painful. When I talked to Muhammad, he was living in Washington, just like Avner, who is also in the United States, Muhammad hopes to go home someday.
我问他被叫做叛徒是什么感觉。对我而言，最伤人、最痛苦的是，没有人支持我。那真的是对我最痛苦的事。还有就是我把一生的心血都奉献给了巴勒斯坦事业，而突然之间我成了这一事业的叛徒，所以这也让人痛苦。当我采访穆罕默德时，他住在华盛顿，就像同样身在美国的阿夫纳一样，穆罕默德希望有一天能回家。
I want to leave you with one last note. As I was learning the stories of Avner and Guariaho and Muhammad Dajani, I went to see a powerful new play called Wrestling Jerusalem. Commissioned by Ari Roth and produced by Mosaic Theater in Washington DC, wrestling Jerusalem is a one-man show that will travel to many parts of the country. Like Avner and Muhammad's real-life stories, the play is about the intertwined traumas of the Nakba and the Holocaust, and the effects those traumas have on the ability of Israelis and Palestinians to empathize with one another. Playwright and performer Aaron Davidman describes his travels in Israel and the occupied territories.
最后，我想留给您一句话。在了解阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡和穆罕默德·达贾尼的故事时，我去看了部极具震撼力的新话剧，名为《摔跤耶路撒冷》（Wrestling Jerusalem）。由阿里·罗斯（Ari Roth）委约创作、华盛顿特区马赛克剧院（Mosaic Theater）制作的《摔跤耶路撒冷》是一部独角戏，将在该国许多地方巡演。就像阿夫纳和穆罕默德的真实生活故事一样，这部话剧讲述了“纳克巴”与大屠杀交织在一起的创伤，以及这些创伤对以色列人和巴勒斯坦人彼此产生同理心能力的影响。剧作家兼表演者亚伦·戴维曼（Aaron Davidman）描述了他在以色列和被占领土的旅行。
You'll hear him speak as himself, and in the voices of Palestinians, and an Israeli man named Nadav. I'm looking for the number 18 bus in East Jerusalem, somewhere up the street from Damascus gate, the Arab entrance to the old city. It's only a few blocks from the Jewish part of Jerusalem, but it feels like another world. The smell of the food vendors, language in the air, gestures of the people in the street, all so different. I can't find the bus stop and have a nervous feeling of being on the other side. I've been to Israel many times. I've never been to Ramallah. When I finally find the small bus, I pay six shekels and I get on. I sit in the back. I'm sure I'm the only Jewish person on the bus, but I feel invisible.
您将听到他以自己的声音，以及巴勒斯坦人和一个名叫纳达夫（Nadav）的以色列男子的声音发言。我在东耶路撒冷寻找 18 路公交车，在距离老城阿拉伯入口大马士革门不远的一条街上。它距离耶路撒冷犹太人区只有几个街区之隔，但感觉就像另一个世界。小贩食物的气味、空气中的语言、街上人们的手势，都是如此不同。我找不到公交车站，有一种身处敌方阵营的紧张感。我去过以色列很多次。我从未去过拉姆安拉。当我终于找到那辆小型公交车时，我付了六谢克尔并上了车。我坐在后面。我确信我是车上唯一的犹太人，但我感觉自己像隐形了一样。
No one seems to pay any attention to me. The atmosphere is quiet, tired. As soon as we get on the highway, the bus is stopped by the Israeli police. Tadut, vaksha! I clutch my passport. I don't want to pass it forward. I just sit there. The officer doesn't see me. Now my invisibility feels conspicuous. There's a blank stare in the eyes of the middle-aged Palestinian men as they pass their IDs forward. Do you speak English? A woman turns to me. Do they ask to see your ID? No. You see how they humiliate us. Ten minutes later, we approach the Kalandia checkpoint. There's a long line of cars and people on foot waiting to cross through.
似乎没有人注意到我。气氛安静而疲惫。我们一上高速公路，公交车就被以色列警察拦了下来。“Tadut, vaksha！”我紧紧抓着护照。我不想把它往前递。我只是坐在那里。警察没有看到我。现在我的隐形感让人觉得格外显眼。中年巴勒斯坦人把身份证往前递时，眼中透出茫然的凝视。“你会说英语吗？”一个女人转向我。“他们要求看你的身份证吗？”“没有。你看他们是怎么羞辱我们的。”十分钟后，我们接近了卡兰迪亚检查站。排着长队的汽车和步行等待过境的人绵延不绝。
Manned by the Israeli Army, Kalandia is one of the few places to cross from Israel into the West Bank and from the West Bank into Israel. Hundreds of kilometers of electric fences, trenches, barbed wire, and eight meter high concrete walls run north and south of this crossing, creating a de facto border. But Selam, the Israeli human rights organization, calls this structure the separation barrier. The Israelis call it the security fence, the Palestinians call it the apartheid wall. Whatever you want to call it, it's massive and intimidating and haunting. The Kalandia Crossing is a rocky, no-man's land, with two giant ominous watchtowers surrounded
由以色列军队把守的卡兰迪亚是从以色列进入约旦河西岸以及从约旦河西岸进入以色列的少数几个过境点之一。数公里的电网、战壕、铁丝网以及八米高的混凝土墙在这处过境点的南北两侧延伸，构成了事实上的边界。但是以色列人权组织“贝采莱姆”（B'Tselem）将这一建筑称为隔离墙。以色列人称之为安全隔离墙，巴勒斯坦人称之为种族隔离墙。不管你想怎么称呼它，它是庞大、威严而又挥之不去的。卡兰迪亚过境处是一片岩石密布的无人区，有两个巨大的、不祥的岗楼，四周环绕着缠绕着铁丝网的栅栏。
by fences laced with barbed wire. Concentration camps. All I can think of is concentration camps. Concentration camps. A lifetime of Holocaust imagery comes lurching forward from the back of my mind. No! Don't think of concentration camps. There's no moral equivalency here. It's not the same. It's not the same guard towers, guard dogs, barbed wire, soldiers, machine guns, refugees, suitcases. Now the Jews are the guards and I'm on the train going into the camps and I I I I
集中营。我脑子里想的全都是集中营。集中营。一生中积累的大屠杀意象从我脑海深处猛地涌现出来。不！不要想集中营。这里没有道德对等。这不是一回事。不是一回事——岗楼、军犬、铁丝网、士兵、机枪、难民、手提箱。现在犹太人成了看守，而我在驶入集中营的火车上，我，我，我，我，我……
I I I remember Nadav and Arun Decraziest thing when I got here. I did not yet know my gilly was on this bus. I did not know I heard on the radio of the pigua, the bumbing, and I come right here. It's my neighborhood. In Haifa we don't expect such things. And I stood here in the street, and I could smell burn flesh in the air, and at that moment
我记起了纳达夫和阿伦。我到这儿时最疯狂的事。我当时还不知道我的吉利在这辆车上。我不知道……我在收音机里听到了袭击、爆炸的消息，然后我直接来到了这里。这是我的街区。在海法，我们从没想过会发生这种事。我站在街上，我能闻到空气中燃烧的肉味，就在那一刻
I had this strange feeling. I thought this must be the smell, the people smelled coming off the trains in Auschwitz, the smell of the crematoriums. My parents were the only survivors of the family to make it out alive. Every other member of the family was killed, every single one, uncles, aunts, everyone completely destroyed and here, sixty years later. My Gilly, burn alive in Stubutal murder, he was thirteen years old. He was in the peace camp for Palestinian and Israeli children just two weeks before. Look, I don't hate the Arabs, but build the wall. Absolutely build the wall. Let them live over there, and we live over here. I'm finished. finished.
我有一种奇怪的感觉。我想这一定就是奥斯威辛火车上的人们闻到的气味，火葬场的气味。我的父母是家族中唯一幸存下来并活着逃出来的人。家族的其他所有成员都被杀了，无一幸免，叔叔、阿姨，所有人彻底消亡……而在这里，六十年后。我的吉利，在野蛮的谋杀中被活活烧死，他才十三岁。就在两周前，他还在巴勒斯坦和以色列儿童和平夏令营。听着，我不恨阿拉伯人，但建墙。绝对要建墙。让他们在那边生活，我们在这边生活。我受够了。受够了。
And I'm staring at this wall of the window of the bus at the Kalandaya checkpoint and six million ghosts chase me as we drive through. And I wonder if they will ever rest. Aaron Davidman performing an excerpt from his play, Wrestling Jerusalem. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Special thanks this week to Ari Roth at Mosaic Theatre and Aaron Davidman for sharing an excerpt from their play. You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. You can listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please consider giving us a review on iTunes.
我正盯着卡兰迪亚检查站公车窗户上的这堵墙，当我们驶过时，六百万个幽灵追逐着我。我想知道他们是否能安息。亚伦·戴维曼表演了他的话剧《摔跤耶路撒冷》的片段。《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛（Karam Agar Kalasin）、玛吉·佩恩曼（Maggie Pennman）和马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）制作。本周特别感谢马赛克剧院的阿里·罗斯和亚伦·戴维曼分享他们话剧的片段。您可以在脸书、推特和 Instagram 上关注我们。您可以在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果您喜欢这集节目，请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们写个评价。
It will help other people find the podcast. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这将帮助其他人找到这个播客。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。